welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar considerations
for scaling evaporation processes
following cannabis six Knutson at the
industrial scales presented by Evan
Moser chief engineer Georgia process my
name is Alexis Morales and I will be
your moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lappers
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Evan Moser I will
now turn the presentation over to him
all right thank you for that wonderful
introduction and today I just want to
get started with presentation on
consideration for scaling evaporation
processes following now I'm going to go
over some industrial scale extraction
equipment and other equipment that falls
in the industry for the cam cannabis and
hemp industry and different applications
for those pieces of equipment so I'm
just kind of going more into the outline
of what we will be doing the canvas
processing workflow so to talk about
scaling evaporation and some of the
equipment that goes with that industry
we need that just kind of a general
understand you know how cannabis
material have material gets to a state
where we need to actually
do evaporation steps so by doing that
will you know have to look at the
current state of cannabis processing
technologies such as extraction solve a
removal molecular distillation and
crystallization with an emphasis
focusing on that solvent removal in the
evaporation side so we'll be looking at
you know what things we have to consider
to scale an evaporation process a lot of
things we see now in industry are more
on the lab scale and what we gotta do to
get an industrial scale and then at the
end of the presentation we would be
going over all some more of those other
types of industrial cannabis equipment
processing all right so so cannabis
processing workflow generally the plant
material is grown in in a greenhouse or
field and then it's got to be extracted
to get an oil or the products inside the
plant material we want to get out that
the process is really called extraction
normally used solvents to get that
material out and by doing that we end up
with a concentrate and we need to
constant we need to do an evaporation
process or a solvent removal process
which we'll be talking further on later
in the presentation
once we remove that solvent though then
we have refinement so we may be getting
a crude oil out of the plant but we need
to look at you know how do we remove the
color any of the fats that could be in
there to make it a much thicker compound
wants being escalation purifying out a
specific product in there so that way
for the final product formulation we're
looking for so whether we're trying to
make a tincture or make a drink
we got to get the crude oil to a product
or a point where we can actually add it
into our food beverage or our most
suitable type product and then from
there you know people would take it and
package it off so a little bit just more
in-depth on the extraction side
there's kind of two sides of extraction
there's mechanical separation which you
know could use a press dry sifters which
just basically tumble the material get
trichomes i'll and then there's more you
know some of the water separation type
technologies that we'll get some of that
material out but won't do a full solid
extraction of the plant material itself
so we firstly have to go into solvent
types of extractions where hydrocarbons
are used to get those oils out along
with there's carbon dioxide at higher
pressures to do extraction processes and
then election alcohol or ethanol
extraction which is becoming more and
more popular just because of the fact
that it's ethanol it's a consumable type
product but the downside of that is a
lot of solvent has to be used and you go
look at using big large-scale
evaporators to get that ethanol back out
so you know concentrating it you know on
a smaller scale rotary evaporator it's
commonly used so you know let's say we
have a couple liters of ethanol mixed
with our products we can use a rotary
batch evaporator getting into a larger
scale would be you know following film
rising film type of operators and then
as it gets more concentrated we got to
get into agitator or white film type of
evaporators and those two right there on
the continuous side we'll get more in
depth than later so for the refinement
side evaporators are used as well but on
a smaller scale so we've removed
ourselves and we still have our crude
oil but it may not be in the form of
what we want or we want to concentrate
the internal products of CBD or THC so
it can be used for that final product
stream we're talking about well right
now a lot of people use soar glass type
distillation or a smaller scale white
film or short path distillation type
products what you can see here on the
right as an example something else that
could be even further purified which we
won't really get into much is
the crystallization process so after we
run it through a short path or a white
film evaporator we can actually take the
product even further in purification and
turn it into a crystal or isolate so
getting more in depth on the evaporation
side so what is an evaporator or you
know why do people need to understand
the fundamentals of an evaporator well
evaporator basically takes a solvent
nasaw you and applies a energy or a heat
and allows us to evaporate off the salt
the solvent so you know these products
would have the solvent and the product
itself have different boiling points so
we're going to use a vapor pressure
we're going to separate them when using
heat being applied to this system so
that way you know it's an easy
separation for us so you know when we're
looking at designs evaporator there's
really some key aspects we have to look
at to do that and then once we
understand those we can look at small
scale and how do we scale it out so the
evaporator itself is really going to be
how do we heat train get the heat into
the product through heat transfer
what is that vapor liquid separation of
those two compounds or multiple
compounds we need to look at and then
initially herb on top of that we need to
look at you know do we do this process
efficiently when you're talking about a
lab scale you know something that's a
couple hundred Watts and not a big deal
but when you start scaling it and you're
talking about millions of BTUs it really
gets energy intensive so one thing about
with the fundamentals of operation we
there's not just one particular
vaporators for every application or one
specific evaporator can cover every
application there's multiple evaporators
out there different design shapes so you
know when looking at scaling evaporation
we also have to look at the product
itself say is it really viscous or is
there following issue you know if
they're high or low in different scales
as you can see the little chart here on
the right kind of says different types
of AB
raishin technologies or evaporator types
that are out there that give us a range
that we can pick from when we start
thinking about which one we're going to
select some other things that kind of go
into that is you know how much product
are we trying to actually deal with and
evaporate so you know if it's a small
amount we may not want to build a really
big type of evaporator if a smaller one
will do also the product characteristics
and then just the overall utilities that
are gonna be required to heat that unit
so with these types of evaporators so
you know there's there multiple types
and we'll get into that in a minute
but every evaporator we kind of have
similar characteristics or process
parameters at which we can control so
you know vacuum level and we pull a
vacuum on the evaporator we can actually
reduce the boiling point of the products
for trying to evaporate giving us
overall lower temperature and protecting
some of the products so organic products
at higher temperatures will break down
well it's not necessarily a good thing
we're actually losing yield and not
going to recover as much of the material
we want or we may burn something else we
can control is how is evaporated being
heated are we gonna use steam hot oil
loops water there's a lot of different
ways we can control the heating media we
can also help the evaporator efficiency
by preheating our product so we can put
the oil into a tank on the front end or
use a heat exchanger in line to preheat
it before it actually gets to the
evaporator which can you know minimize
the heat up time in there and and
utilize that evaporator and actually we
can size down the evaporator by
preheating because they largely get the
more expensive they get and then overall
surface area of that evaporator how much
surface area is going to be required for
this particular product you know will
scale it accordingly and then something
that last ball point there that rotor
tip speed is really only on white film
evaporators actually then film
evaporators
I'll get a little bit more detail in a
second so we got also look at what
impacts how fast we can evaporate when
we're gonna look at scaling up our
evaporation process so as I kind of
mentioned earlier our heating media you
know what utility are we going to heat
this system with but then we can start
looking at materials of construction we
build it out of stainless versus carbon
steel we look at you know if the solvent
that we're putting in there can flash
too fast that'll actually put a lot of
heat load on the system so how much
solvent we're putting in there in the
operating temperature of that and then
the vapor velocity as that really gets
into the design of the interior
components of that actual evaporator so
you know as I mentioned a little bit
earlier we kind of looked at a chart
that talked about look at our products
and what types of operators we should
pick or you know what range of
evaporation technologies fit into our
scope of what we're trying to size and
build so there's long tube evaporators
which are called common name is a rising
film evaporator if people know what a
shell on tube is it's really just
putting a long show into single pass
vertically following film would also
fall into that same type of showing to
the heat exchanger you're gonna have a
product on the tube side and it's gonna
be very similar to the vertical rising
film but the product flows the opposite
way and there's no mechanical
interaction in this type of evaporator
it's all gravity based which you know
requires less maintenance and work a
little bit differently but also can't
have as viscous type of materials
because they just don't function as well
and then we get into the mechanically
agitated type of evaporators white film
evaporators they have anterior paddles
and agitated then some of the operators
also do and then a short path is very
similar to those that have paddles in it
but also has an internal component
that's slightly different which I'll
discuss in a minute
so just a little bit more understanding
the rising film evaporator as you can
see the picture on the right product
will feed into the bottom up into the
heat exchanger on one side of that heat
exchanger there will be steam or a
heating medium that's applying heat to
our products it's not in direct contact
there's actually tubes inside this unit
those tubes are being heated product
flows in there as it's heated the
solvent material in there will start to
heat up and boil trading vapor flow and
cause the product to move and separate
or move up in through the unit and go
into the vapor liquid separator as you
see on the right towards the top vapor
will go one way and our product will
come out the bottom so we're essentially
removing our solvent left with our
products in a rising type of fashion for
the hemp cannabis industry is now it's
commonly used unless there's a large
residual amount of solvent to be removed
following film a little bit more common
on the smaller side for the incoming
cannabis and hemp industry being that
it's a thicker type material it flows
slow and uses gravity to flow down so
looking at the picture on the right
there our product will feed into the top
our steam or heating medium will be on
the shell side again but instead of our
product rising up it'll actually go in a
downward direction using gravity and as
it gets towards the bottom the vapor
will come out to vapor liquid separator
on the right and our product come off
the bottom one nice kind of feature of
this is you can actually recycle that so
you can get a second pass on it to make
sure you get all residual solvent out so
white film and edited thin film
evaporators use a mechanical type device
interior to their design so if you look
at the picture
or the images on the right there that's
kind of a chopped view showing the
paddle actually moving the products so
so the solvent mixture when the oil will
actually come in at the top the paddle
will come around and spin and wipe it
along the wall now the speed of that
rotor is pretty critical we want to make
sure they were actually building up a
decent amount of material where it's
actually kind of turning the product
over on itself it's called the
phenomenon of the bow wave very
important for white film evaporators
thin film or agitated thin film
evaporators if you're getting low yield
out of it it's probably because you're
actually not operating at the right
parameters and it's normally because the
bow wave phenomenon nice thing about
this is they can handle very thick
materials low resonance time and you can
move a lot of product through these with
a smaller design so the short path is
very similar to the white film or thin
film evaporators works on the same
concept the only difference is the wiper
design is a little bit different where
it will have an internal condenser so if
you're looking at the picture on the
right there there's kind of the green in
blue that is a condenser so what happens
is product will feed on the top the
wiper will wipe it around the wall but
as it's being heated part of the
compound that's lighter or boiling off
or it could be solvent in this case will
travel very short distance to the
condenser to the center and actually be
condensed out before it leaves the unit
by doing that it allows us to pull
deeper vacuums on here so we can lower
our boiling points even more it also
allows us to not have any external
components it's all one tight unit and
it also is where it gets its name it's a
short path the evaporation sequence
happens from the exterior wall to the
interior condenser in a matter of you
know inches feet whatever the size of
the unit is versus
traveling outside of pipe to another
unit so you know short paths for the
cannabis and hemp industries it's
starting to become a more and more
common thing one for the deeper
capability of the vacuum you know as I
just mentioned it drives our
temperatures down so when we're trying
to concentrate CBD and THC we don't want
to operate those at too high a
temperature where we start degrading the
material obviously don't organic
compound side of it you know get it too
hot it'll break down and we won't be
left with the same product and reduce
our yield it's also very beneficial for
this industry from the short residence
we're now not spending a lot of time in
there goes right back to you know not
degrading the product and then you know
if you've handled this material or seen
this material it's fairly viscous so to
have those panels and they're moving it
around this works really well to get it
through the system so now we kind of
understand what the vaporators are the
key characteristics that we got to look
at when picking evaporator looking at an
evaporator you know how do we size up
from the smaller scale evaporators that
we've seen maybe in a lab to something
we see an industrial type of environment
really there's a lot of things you can
look at the biggest one is what we call
the overall heat transfer coefficient
it's commonly used in a lot of heat
exchange applications well we also
utilize it when sizing the different
types of evaporators where there's a non
mechanical type of evaporator or
mechanical and basically what it is is a
buildup of how well we can get our
heating medium like steam or oil to heat
up our product on the inside to create
that separation type of process so our
overall heat transfer coefficient this
is just a formula I wanted to show it in
the presentation I'm not going to get
too much depth about each component of
it but it's just
build up we know how much heat it's
going to require to create the
separation process here's all the things
that are required to make this happen
into our formula so I know they're just
kind of breakdown of that overall heat
transfer coefficient when we really
start getting into what that you value
is when we think about us are our
product flows down through this
evaporator up through this evaporator we
call that a thin film heat transfer
coefficient low will also have the same
on the steam or heating utility side and
then we'll also have the limitation of
the wall this the metal wall that's
between the two the either the heating
medium and actual product so we got to
add what we call those are like
resistances that each can only take you
so much heat transfer at a time and they
limit how well we can transfer the heat
into the product that we're trying to
separate or that solvent oil mixture or
even on a molecular distillation type of
level of concentrating our CBD and THC
how much heat we can get actually get
into the product to separate it so just
looking at the equations on the left the
top one is our outer thin film
coefficient the cube would be in the
middle is the wall resistance and then
obviously the product one is the last
one so adding those three together
changes how well we get that overall
heat transfer coefficient value just
going a little bit more detail so well
with those equations now we kind of put
those three together that very first
equation there is the buildup of those
three coefficients to get us at U value
and once I get in the next couple slides
you'll see how important that you that
is so just an example to kind of really
show how important those three
characteristics there are so that
outside and that inside film coefficient
if on this example just shows you know
we're getting in this example heat
transfer of 155 now if I go to the next
slide we show we
or change one of those film coefficients
let's say we went from an oil heating
method to a steam heating method it
would change how much heat transfer
we're getting into the evaporator so you
can see in the bottom left corner there
it says our heat transfer is now 253 on
the last side it was by 153 so for us
just change say a flow rate or a
temperature of operation on our utility
side or that heating medium we can
change how much heat is being applied to
the product side on the actual
evaporator so knowing those values we
can get a good view value and then we
can get into okay so we understand what
are you values how do we take that
information and scale it well let's say
we have a laboratory evaporator we can
run tests on that evaporator with the
product we want to scale - and we can
basically back calculate these equations
here on the right so our sensible heat
sensible heat is basically looking at
how well the heat is actually getting
into the product how much heat is
required to create a separation process
we're looking at in the evaporator
latent heat is how much energy it takes
to actually turn it into a vapor and
then our process superheat is how how is
it going to get once we actually
evaporate it so we can back calculate
those and that gives us what we call
like overall you value for this whole
small scale evaporator so tiny little
lab skill operator well now we want to
build a bigger one we want to build one
that can use five times the rate so we
got a u value for our lab scale and then
we can take that we can plug it into it
basically compare some type of equation
and get it what we call corrected U
value so our bigger evaporator may have
thicker walls and a different type of
heating process because it's just more
effective well what we do is we enter
that information it gives there's a
corrected u value so that way we can
properly design that larger scale
evaporator so we go through you know all
those
resistances in the u-value equation or
overall heat transfer coefficient
equation from say a lab scale and scale
it up to a large scale so a lot of times
in you know scaling them to an
industrial size we either have have
processed data or a small test scale so
something like we have here in our
facility we have test units you know you
can ticket a product that is no one run
it through get an effective you value
out of it go back and calculate those
few equations that I just showed plug in
into our corrected you value equation
and scale it up very easily and know
that it's it's gonna work into the
parameters that we want so you know just
kind of looking at okay every vaporators
different every evaporators gonna have a
different you value you know that test
pilot test get the values we need
punched into this equation and i'll give
you how easy it is to to scale it up and
and what it's actually gonna take to do
it so that's kind of it on the scaling
up side a last little bit here i just
want to go over some other industrial
type of processing for the cannabis and
hemp industry so it kind of go more
detail on the front end and back into
why you know it would be important to
have an evaporator that's a larger scale
and why you would even need it so i'm
just gonna go into a couple things quick
different pieces of equipment for some
examples so you know the beginning the
presentation talked a little bit about
extraction rotary extraction is a
solvent based process extraction that
uses a lot of solvent something like
this would be running about four
thousand pounds an hour of solvent but
that would be mixed with your oil and
then you would send it downstream to a
large scale evaporator you know they new
batch sizes of you know something like
this and the right image here we're
doing it from fifty to a thousand pounds
of cannabis or ham per hour
I don't think it you know it's a lot of
solvent and you're gonna need a pretty
big evaporator to process that much
solvent oil mixture
another type of mechanical extraction
unit
that also uses a lot of solvent and
requires an evaporator or this one it
here itself actually has an evaporator
built into it but basically uses large
mix tanks Sol liquid solid separator in
a decanter and you're left with a
solvent stream mixed with old oil that
has to go to an evaporation process now
like this type of unit has what we call
like a small-scale agitated evaporator
on it and then it would go from here to
say like a white film evaporator and so
just kind of reiterating on the solvent
recovery side or our evaporators in
general this is a batch style kettle
evaporator so it has an agitator in it
and it uses thin film type of technology
that we had just discussed earlier to
move remove solvent and leave you with
the oil the image to the right there is
actually a white film evaporator that
would be used more like on that Rotex or
rotary type of extractor to recover the
solvent back out and get the crude oil
so you know if we have large-scale
extractors and we have large-scale
evaporators we're also going to be
larger scale type of processing for that
crude oil to get it refined a process
that commonly needs to be done on a
small scale is winterization and removal
fats this is you know just a general
process of mixing it with the solvent
cooling it down and crystallizing those
fats out you know the image in the
middle there is actually a winterization
type skin where those that would happen
in those mixed tanks and then there's
some filters on the front there where
those fats would be filtered out those
colors could be removed as we had talked
earlier short paths distillation this
unit here on the right can do 50 litres
an hour I think a lot of units and a lab
scale right now around three to five
liters an hour so you can see the scale
up size
but it can also be set up to be a short
path distillation unit as well so if
somebody needed to concentrate their CBD
or THC you would run your product
through after you've run your solvent
out of it to concentrate it and this
same unit can do both and then isolates
and crystallization on a larger scale
would look something similar to what a
winterization unit is but there's no
picture here so it's kind of harder to
explain how you would get that there so
solving processing I want to go over the
just briefly I think as people see
systems grow and we talked about you
know we need large-scale evaporators to
get this solvent back a lot of times
that solvent comes off the evaporator
it's not going to be pure so we actually
need to repair by it or make more of it
we may lose some of that due to vacuum
systems or just residual left over in
the system
so solvents actually keep you made on a
pretty easy system of you know
biologically from any net using beasts
and sugars or naturally with our
synthetically with ethane and steam
which is more of an industrial type
application a lot of ethanol or yeah
ethanol being used as a solvent in the
cannabis and hemp industry is actually
being manufactured via fermentation well
once you ferment it you got to actually
run it through a still which just so
happens to take an evaporator to
concentrate but then it actually goes
into a fractional column to purify it
and then something else with you know
ethanol being using these processes the
point material may not always come in
perfectly dry well that moisture gets
pulled out if you use an ethanol or
other types of solvents and we can
actually run that through what's called
a molecular sieve or a molecular
distillation column which is really just
a large skinny tank full of a packed bed
material and that's all that's run
through it and at that point the salt
the molecular sieve pulls the moisture
out and leaves you with clean solvent
for reuse so that was kind of the
equipment I just want to go over it so
you can kind of see there all
our other industrial types of equipment
I have to get scaled up I know we spent
most the time out of operation but I
hope from seeing some of the horn to us
just some of the general understandings
of the different types of evaporators
out there that you can see you know the
different applications and maybe when
you're talking to a vendor or engineer
or somebody trying to get your system
scaled up or you're interested in the
industry and see you know there's a
little bit more to it than just saying I
want that bigger unit I hope that kind
gives you a background an understanding
of that that's it for my presentation I
just want to thank lab roots for the
opportunity to go over you know the
cannabis have process on a general
process flow and then some of the larger
equipment and and giving me some time to
spend go over the evaporation technology
and what's all involved when we have to
scale smaller scale small units to a
larger scale thank you
Thank You Evan for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2019 as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time goodbye